[Music]  you'd think that brad pitt would be  taking things down a notch after he re  released that that kind of ridiculous  chanel number five commercial  that went everywhere you'd think he'd be  doing what he can to move away from that  but as we've seen lately he's not yeah  yeah  look at this uh recent interview brad  pitt did on good morning america  you have a birthday coming up  yeah in a month and next year is the big  one when you turn  50 50.  have you given any thought to that  yeah i've given a lot of thought to it  um  um you've become i just turned 50. so  it's not a journey every journey ends  but we go on world turns and we turn  with it  plans disappear  dreams take over but wherever i go there  you are  my luck  my fate  my fortune really yeah  number five  [Applause]  it doesn't even fit organically into the  conversation  he keeps saying chanel number five he he  loves chanel number five i know he  should it's an amazing product